hello reject nation it is Greg Alba here
and it is John Humphrey here John is
moving to New York
today that's right I am never returned
so sad he leaves tonight I did not offer
to drive him to the airport but I did
offer to let him be in a video with me
oh that's really a privilege to me
honestly that's what I care about
we both have bed head looks no different
from our regular hair Matt Damon ruins
chris hemsworth interview oh boy
something tells me that if the title
didn't say that this video would have
been more surprising well you know who
likes the surprise anyway no one no one
let me tell you what happens at the end
of Blade Runner
would you bring here with you backstage
yeah there's a few we've got talker what
CD director director yes yo Mark Ruffalo
[Music]
[Applause]
by far the best version and I like the
previous version so yeah could be too
fake looking again and and talk I said
I'd do what we've done before and Mark
on many occasions looked at me and said
we wrecking this film I think we have a
camera backstage let's see if Mark is
back there
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a beautiful Hulk you put
together Thank You Jamie it's weird to
see you in clothes usually you're all
like naked strange you guys you guys
must be pals for mark to come along with
you to this oh yeah I'm so sorry he's
not supposed to go into the guest rooms
he's is an area that he's supposed to 16
hours away from my house
good is there a rivalry between people
from New Zealand as you are and people
from Australia yeah sadly there is it's
been just become thousands of years this
is what why are you friends with no
sorry friend is it true you go on
vacations with them well he turned up oh
really is that right likes to go to
things that no one wants does he stay in
your house when I told you oh no yeah
and these kids as well Wow nice enough
yeah we found the kids I don't hold it
against the kids you told you the kids
are nicer yeah yeah
[Applause]
I've been here for a really long time
Jimmy decades yes I learned a lot of
stuff go backstage you need the duty
potatoes that we made for you okay all
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so sorry Chris I really am what we
cut online we are hopefully going to see
an exclusive
I am Jimmy Kimmel if you like that click
the subscribe button
dang yeah we're probably not gonna watch
that clip I would like to see something
fresh in the actor he comes out in a
couple weeks
yeah I think it's actually a great
promotional material to infuse like a
comedy bit like they like the
reoccurring bit of a Matt Damon
especially after hearing just how
hilarious this new Thor movie is yeah
you know you got a comedy director like
Tiki Watts working on this movie because
I was thinking about it like while it
was going on I'm like well they're here
to promote thor ragnarok does this help
promote thor ragnarok but it kind of
does help promote thor ragnarok
because a it doesn't need any more help
with promotion yeah this is just gonna
bring in people who just kind of like
Matt Damon owns in more on the comedic
valuable side of it you know I feel like
they have a lot more fun with the cast
when it is more like with the Marvel
promotions when the Marvel films a
little bit more comedic well yeah and
then leading with fun and goodwill and
and all that you know has been every bit
of approach they've kind of taken with
this movie and I think that this does
kind of work in that regard you know
it's you've got the three sort of main
players of this new movie and the
mockumentary loyalist I Iike yeah yeah
yeah being trolled by by Jimmy Kimmel's
personal meme which is mad yeah yeah in
terms of just like building a little
extra goodwill for the rest of America
might not be so interested I think it's
pretty effective and I just to see
giant-man yeah just to see them like
pull back the curtain that way and be
like this isn't a real backdrop and you
know it's not a real backdrop like to
really be like nah this is a screen and
now Matt Damon's taller than everybody
like I I that that tickled me I love all
the Matt Damon stuff there every once in
a while I just binge watch it all over
again I told like the Matt Damon bits on
the Jimmy Kimmel show it's one of the
funniest reoccurring misses it started
out so authentically
that Damon just couldn't actually make
the show yeah and and then over time I
just turned into this big reoccurring
jab it jimmy kimmel dude he is Las Vegas
Beach I have everyone moves very moving
speech I've seen him give a couple
pretty moving speeches after very
serious events taking place he got very
emotional yeah it's like one of those
videos were is like fighting back tears
but when a man fights back tears that
makes me as a viewer to go he's fighting
back tears and I'm weeping all my crying
[Music]
well thanks for sending that our way I
can't wait for the Thor Ragnarok we
already have our tickets oh yeah Tiki
Watts baby I can't watch the great
director Mani easy to remember name I'm
glad he changed yeah yeah psycho white
TV is really hard to remove is subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification valve dad John Humphrey on
Twitter Instagram follow him because
he's gonna be New York and I'm sure
he'll have some Instagram story's Hicks
and patreon is a website that exists
what do you do there go there to find
out hey search the real rejects and who
knows maybe I'll win a prize